um keeping with the spirit of that idea
we're going to record everyone but we're
only going to post people on the website
who want to be posted on their website
um all right so we'll start with Greg
I'm looking for about 20 minutes per
speaker
awesome thanks
um looking forward to chatting about
something I'm today going to talk about
the reason that I didn't finish my PhD
as quickly as I expected to
um because the kernel of this idea kind
of came into my head when I was like
almost done with my dissertation and
then it ended up turning into a full
chapter
um so yeah I'm gonna specifically be
talking about doing arithmetic on
quantum computers um which is something
people were excited about in like 2004
uh when I was learning how to do like
regular arithmetic
um
um but it turns out um It's actually
kind of getting exciting again so the uh
the reason let's see if I can get this
thing working or I can just use my
computer
um
the reason I started thinking about this
is because
um I've been thinking about these
questions of how we can uh sort of like
verify Quantum Advantage efficiently on
a classical computer and for this um I
was specifically focusing on trying to
implement the function x squared mod n
um but what I ended up coming up with it
turns out is relevant for just doing
multiplication in general so it can also
be used for other types of cryptography
like maybe lattice cryptography
um and also things sort of anything that
uses arithmetic on quantum computers
including Shore's algorithm
so um just to be very clear about what
I'm going to talk about today I just
want to implement the following
unitaries so this one I'll call Quantum
times Quantum multiplication which is uh
two integers you know just represented
as bit strings in two Quantum registers
we're going to multiply them together
and put the result in the third register
um and the other is what I call
classical times Quantum multiplication
where you define some unitary uh that's
parametrized by an integer a and you're
multiplying the thing that's in this uh
Quantum register by a and putting it in
the second register and you don't care
answer register or something other than
zero that's a good question actually so
it turns out what I'm going to show you
trivially you can have something in the
answer register and it'll just add it to
that for Simplicity in this talk I'm
just going to leave it as you are though
good
um and the goal is to do this kind of as
quickly as possible in terms of gates
and and number of qubits
um okay so you know it's going to be a
20 minute talk we're kind of going to
crank through it I'm going to try to not
get bogged down in questions
um but you know you can chat with me
later uh if you're interested in that
we're going to start out talking about
fast multiplication in general not
Quantum then we're going to be talking
about a specific technique for Quantum
multiplication and then we're going to
try to smush them together the goal is
for me to set this up in a way that it's
like so obvious you'll be like okay yeah
obviously we should use this algorithm
and then I'm going to actually try to
convince you why it's not obvious and
then show you how to make it work
okay so the classic way of doing
multiplication which uh is what I was
learning 20 years ago when people were
excited about this in school
um although it wasn't in binary at the
time it was probably in base 10.
um so
um is where you just basically multiply
the individual digits
um each of the individual digits and
then sum them up you know scaled by the
power of the base that you're interested
in
um and then you get the answer uh the
running time of this is pretty
straightforward it's N squared because
there's n Bits in each of the values and
then you know you have to take every
combination of them
um and we can use any base we want so
what I'm going to kind of jump into now
is say what if we instead use the base
um b equals 2 to the N over two so
essentially we're forcing our numbers to
each have two digits okay
then our multiplication looks like this
and we end up with this expression at
the bottom where we have like each of
their products and then various uh
factors of B which is you know this base
this big base that we're using
um doing this hasn't already given us
anything because if we do each of these
smaller multiplications using you know
regular binary school book
multiplication they're each going to
take n over 2 squared and there's four
of them so we get just N squared again
we haven't won anything
um but now we're going to make an
observation and this is kind of cool
even if you're not thinking about
Quantum stuff you can learn a new thing
or it's probably not a new thing for a
lot of you but you can learn something
cool about multiplying numbers
um it turns out we actually don't need
to do four of these multiplications we
only have to do three
and the observation we're going to make
is that
uh when we make
this product it's actually going to be
this middle term and then uh plus the
two other terms that we're Computing and
the idea is because we already have to
compute X1 y1 and x0 Y zero uh just to
find these other two things then we only
have to do one further multiplication
subtract those two things off and then
we get this middle term and now we've
done it only with three multiplications
which is pretty cool
again if we do school book
multiplication for these smaller
multiplications this actually doesn't
give us anything in terms of the
asymptotic scaling it's given us a
factor of three quarters but you know
since those smaller ones are still N
squared it's it's not ideal
but we can do something uh I guess a
little more clever and do this
recursively so the idea is we take this
big multiplication break it up into
three smaller multiplications and then
break each of those into three smaller
multiplications and keep going
um just kind of looking at it back at
the envelope the depth is going to be
log base 2 of this length n
um the number of operations will be
proportional to three to the depth
um we can also look at it as this
recursion relation where the time taken
to do a multiplication of size n is
three times the time taken to do a
multiplication of size n over two but
the moral of the story is that if we
solve these things we're going to
actually get up get n to the log 2 of 3
which is n to the 1.58 so we're already
winning Over N squared uh super quickly
since I don't have a ton of time
yeah so this is actually not exactly
shown how gastrosson um because that one
ends up getting down to roughly n log n
this is like
a similar idea though I guess I would
say
um
um roughly yeah we can chat about it
after if you want that connection but
that that's a good question
okay so you might ask why don't we just
always do this classically because it
seems like it's faster and it's because
we have to do this extra uh additions of
these intermediate products that
introduces some constant which is an
extra cost and that that extra constant
isn't always worth it for large enough
values it is so I looked up the new
multi-precision arithmetic Library where
they make this cut off when they're
multiplying over roughly 2000 bit
numbers they decide to switch uh out of
the schoolbook method
um we can take this a little bit further
actually with something called tomb cook
where instead of splitting it only into
two chunks we split it into K chunks um
of n over K bits each and it turns out
um I don't have time to talk about it
right now but it turns out that you can
do 2K minus one multiplications of this
size instead of K squared so you keep
winning more the higher you make K the
problem is that you get larger and
larger constants out front
um but this is the asymptotic scaling
that you get for various values of K as
I said a moment ago you don't want to
take it too big otherwise your constants
are going to blow up and even though the
scaling is good it's just not going to
be worth it
um okay so that's all I wanted to say
about like classically multiplying
numbers quickly
um but we're going to use it in a moment
um the main takeaways are that the sort
of standard schoolbook multiplication
requires and squared operations there
are these faster algorithms but they
sometimes have these large constant
factors that uh that cause them to not
be worth it unless and is fairly big
okay so now I'm going to jump to a
technique for Quantum multiplication
which uh requires very few qubits oh
sorry actually first I want to talk
about
um whether we can just make these fast
circuits Quantum
um the Big Challenge here is that right
we have this like tree structure and we
want to make these circuits reversible
and the problem is that if we need to
uncompute intermediate results as we're
doing this recursion we kind of need to
store these intermediate results as we
go down the tree and then use them in
the uncomputation
so the first try at this was using
essentially as much space as the runtime
of the algorithm by being kind of clever
about the dependencies between values in
here you can get it a little bit lower
and then actually recently
um there was this very clever result
from kidney which figures out how to do
it in what one could call like a tail
recursive way to get the number of
qubits all the way down to order n which
is very cool
um but you know order n is the
asymptotic scaling if you kind of run
the circuits that get me implemented in
Q sharp you see that you end up with
something like 12 000 and silicubits to
do a 2048-bit multiplication and our
question is whether we can make this
constant better
um and in this talk I'm actually going
to claim that we can get it down to one
Ancilla
um so yeah I'll show you how to do that
uh just now or actually okay quick other
background thing I need to talk about
super quickly we're going to be talking
about a fundamentally Quantum way of
doing arithmetic which is um doing it in
four-year space so I just wrote down
Quantum Fourier transform here
um and this idea which I believe
originated with with a paper by Draper
in o4
um is you know if the product we want is
X Y
um the Fourier transformed version of
this product looks like this
and we can observe that um
then we can implement this product by
doing the following taking this last
register into Fourier space so that ends
up looking like if it starts with zero
just a uniform superposition over Z
then we're going to apply this phase
which is the phase that we're talking
about here
and then we're just going to Fourier
transform back and magically this
product X Y is going to pop out so this
is kind of nice
um and it's especially nice because you
can actually see
um you don't need any incyllabus for
this uh kind of directly right so you
can do the quantum Fourier transform
without incellus and then I'll show you
can actually apply this phase without
instant list two so
um this is nice for saving space
how do we actually apply this phase well
you know I talked about the schoolbook
decomposition of X Y it turns out we can
just kind of extend it to XYZ by putting
another factor of a bit of Z in there
and we're going to end up with something
that looks like this so we've just
broken down this phase into the product
of a bunch of smaller phases the nice
thing about this product is
that this product here is all of binary
values so this is just saying apply this
phase if all of these qubits are one
um so this is just a doubly controlled
phase rotation on the bits of X Y and Z
okay so we can actually implement this
phase by just doing a a bunch of uh
doubly controlled phase rotations
the downside is that because we have
three indices now this requires n Cube
Gates so
this is you know a factor of n worse
than we got doing the classical or sorry
doing the N squared algorithm we
actually win that factor event back if
we're only talking about classical
Quantum multiplication instead of
quantum Quantum multiplication
and uh this is because we can just kind
of lump this classical value into the
phase we don't have to multiply by the
individual bits of it so then we end up
doing a product between two n bit values
but actually one of them didn't even
exist before it's the result of doing
this Fourier transform and then we're
shoving this other input value into the
phase and we end up with N squared
so this is kind of nice we've matched
the schoolbook algorithm without uh uh
without needing any extra qubits
okay so the main question is can we just
smush these two things together and get
something that's fast and doesn't use
very many qubits
we're going to start with this classical
Quantum case because it's a little bit
more straightforward
our goal is to apply this phase as I
just said where both x and z are stored
in Quantum registers
I'm going to generalize this a little by
defining this thing I'll call phase
product which is just essentially you
give it some phase five and then it
gives you the product of these two
things times Phi okay
um so we want to split it into the sum
of many phases Each of which is easy to
implement the way we did this before was
by doing it through a bunch of
controlled phase rotations which we
ended up with N squared of them
let's see if we can use this cart super
vcom decomposition to do this so this is
this fancy decomposition I wrote down
before in which you only need to do
three multiplications
but now is when we run into a big
problem
so breaking down the phase it'll look
like this and the whole point of doing
cartsuba is that we were going to reuse
the values we computed in the first two
multiplications in order to make this
one more efficient
but they're in the phase right once we
apply these phases it's not like we can
somehow magically get X1 Z1 and X zero
zero zero back out so then we can
subtract it off of there
so we can actually get around this and
the way we're going to do it
is by rearranging this decomposition so
this is what we had
what we're actually going to do is take
these two things and just like regroup
them over into these terms
so now we have something that looks like
this
this would be a bad idea classically
because now the whole point was we were
only shifting by like a power of two so
scaling by these powers of two didn't
cost anything but now we're starting to
get like complicated things that we're
multiplying by this which seems like a
bad idea the reason it's totally fine
here is that these phases were Computing
classically when we're compiling the
circuit so we can just do this in
classical pre-computation and then not
have to worry about it when we're
actually running the quantum circuit so
now we actually have a really beautiful
structure where in order to implement
this phase that we have here we just
need to implement three phases Each of
which involve a product of uh only n
over two bits rather than n Bits
um with the phase that we have to rotate
by adjusted by these prefactors which we
can find classically
so
um
so yeah we can do this recursively just
like we did in the other case
um and we end up with a complexity uh
that has the same recursion relation and
we end up with n to the 1.58 uh Gates
Again which is super nice
um let's look at how many qubits we need
so if we just split these registers in
half we can just immediately Implement
these things right because we just have
those values
what do we do about these sums well it
might seem like we need a lot more
qubits to store these sums in but
remember we can just do these first and
then because addition is reversible we
can do it in place so we can store this
x0 plus X1 just we can just overwrite
one of the X values with it
so it almost feels like we can use zero
incillas the reason we can't quite get
there is because this Value x0 Plus X1
is just a little bit too big right so we
need one extra qubit to store the
Overflow bit of that in of that that
thing and actually
um I don't have time to go into it right
now but this actually could become a big
problem because we're recursing and if
we keep doing this every time we're
going to like accumulate these and Silas
throughout every level of recursion but
there's a clever trick you can do to
basically trim it off and reuse it at
lower levels of of recursion so that you
don't need to accumulate them as you go
okay so now we're going to tackle the
harder case which is quantum Quantum
multiplication
the problem here is that we have this
triple product rather than just uh just
a single product of two integers
which I'll call the phase dribble
product like I defined before
okay
um so the way we did this before was
with nqw controlled phase rotations by
breaking down the face like this
obviously n cubed is like really bad we
want to avoid that
um classically if we needed to compute
the product of three integers there's a
really straightforward way of doing it
we just put parentheses around Y and Z
compute that product and then multiply
by the other value and it's just still N
squared this is nice
the problem is for the same reason as
before we can't like get YZ out after
we've computed it right so we need to
somehow do this triple product like all
at once
um let's say we break these three
integers each into two parts like we did
uh in the regular cart super method
um then we have to do eight
multiplications of size n over two right
like every possible combination of these
two these two pieces of three different
integers
um one might ask is there a
decomposition like cartsuba for this
triple product
it turns out there is I don't think
anyone's written this down probably
because it's like a really bad idea
classically as I said before right you
should never do this but in this case um
it actually is super duper helpful
um and now we're only doing four
multiplications of length n over two
instead of eight we've cut this down by
a lot
we get this recursion relation
it's a little bit sad right off the bat
because we're like okay we got down to N
squared fine but it turns out like we
did before we can break it into K pieces
instead of two
and then we start getting exponents on
these ends that are below N squared
um and it turns out due to some subtlety
of how you trim off these extra qubits
like I mentioned before you actually
need two instead of one in this case
um okay so now I want to Super quickly
chat about depth
um parallelization is actually super
kind of natural in here because you know
we're going down these different sides
of the tree so we can for example do
this one and this one at the same time
um we can't do all three at the same
time without using extra qubits remember
because uh we're overwriting one of them
with uh with this this value
well we actually run into a little bit
of a problem if we want to go past depth
order n so yeah since our run time is
you know below N squared and we have n
qubits we could hope for getting as good
as like n to the 0.58 right something
sublinear
um surprisingly we actually run into a
bottleneck in that at least personally I
don't know how to do a Quantum Fourier
transform using this few ancillas in
depth less than order n
um so if someone knows how to do that
already in the audience that would make
this stronger which would be cool
um but it's an interesting thing to
think about anyway but that's actually
the main problem so doing the if you're
willing to use order and ancillas
because you also need to do additions
which as far as I know can't be done in
in less than order and time with you
know just one or two and so is
um you can actually Implement these the
important maybe operations these face
product and face dribble product
operations using in sublinear time so
like the the hard part seems to have
actually gotten easy like sublinear time
in the middle it's actually this qft
that that I seem to be running into as
as preventing the whole thing from being
sub-linear time
okay the last thing I want to chat about
super quickly because I think I'm almost
out of time is how to do modular
arithmetic so far
um The Phases we've been looking at have
the denominator of 2 to the N because
this is the Quantum Fourier transform
we're doing right we're doing a Quantum
Fourier transform modulo to the n
um we can make a new subservation is
that if we replace this modulo with
whatever our modulus n is instead of 2
to the N the phase wraps around so we
kind of get the modular operation
automatically which is really nice the
challenge is that you know if you were
to do it directly then you'd have to do
a inverse Quantum Fourier transform
modulo n which is a lot harder than
doing one modulo a power of two
so what I actually suggest doing is that
we can just Define some binary fraction
this is kind of like what we do in in
Quantum phase estimation and just
compute some binary fraction that like
corresponds to this fraction X Y mod n
over n and then that this actually will
suffice for for our purposes most of the
time
um
and so we've lost our like nice one or
two qubits now you know this will be
imprecise and it'll require uh log one
over Epsilon qubits to get to a
Precision Epsilon
um and something I'm really interested
in is if someone could come up with a
clever way to get it back down to to
order one so just to summarize the
results since I think I'm pretty much
out of time for both classical Quantum
and Quantum Quantum multiplication we
can get these sub uh quadratic
multiplication times using only one or
two n silicubits
um the implications are that we can run
Shore's algorithm and only end the 2.46
time say if we use this one using 2N
plus log n qubits which to my knowledge
is like the best asymptotic scaling for
Schwarz algorithm in this much space
that people know
um
another uh sort of corollary that I
haven't mentioned is that you can
actually do an exact Quantum Fourier
transform in this amount of time instead
of N squared using only one Ancilla
which is kind of cool
um
and yeah to move on to some open
questions
um as I mentioned earlier I wonder if we
can do the modulo part in also using
only order one ancillas
um I wonder if this qft can be done in
sublinear depth without needing a lot of
insulin so that we can do the whole
thing in sublinear depth
whether we can do any of these these
things somehow cleverly with zero encels
would be very cool it's not clear to me
if that's possible it's like you know
somehow deal with this overflow problem
and the big question to me is like how
well can we optimize explicit circuits
for this it actually seems very
promising that this could win at
practical sizes with the reason being
um
because we're doing this uh
this sort of like adjusting the phase on
a classical computer during circuit
compilation
um we're actually taking a lot of the
work of reconstituting the value in
carat super multiplication out of the
quantum circuit and putting it into this
classical precomputation so I think we
actually are cutting down a lot on the
overhead that normally comes with
cartsuba by doing this and I feel like
if we build explicit circuits for this
they could actually be quite fast
um that's all I have time for and
actually unfortunately I'm traveling
tonight so I have to run pretty much
right after this talk
um so um but if you want to chat about
this more or have any questions or
whatever here's my email I live in
Berkeley at least until the end of
August so
um you know if you're around feel free
to
send me an email and we can chat
um thank you so much for your time
[Applause]
um let me demike myself in that yeah
so
I'm staying almost a post-op with my
grad student advisor Norm for a little
while
um and then yeah I'm still figuring out
what I'm gonna do after that so all
right all right
yes this was awesome yeah thanks so much
nice to see you yeah
hello
noise is something that's present in all
types of quantum Harvest of today
and I presume one of the challenges of
this period is to still get something
nice from our noisy quantum computers
some sort of a like a nice demonstration
of quantum speed up perhaps
so what is one proposal like like one
type of demonstration for Quantum
speedups this is random circuit sampling
the task is sampling from the
distribution the final distribution of
random circuits and this is like the
Bedrock of many of the like the
demonstrations that you see which try to
say that quantum computers are maybe
Superior to classical computers in some
sense
so how does this work
so we have let's say a circuit of this
form the white rectangles are random
Gates
and the pink rectangles are noise
channels
and the task once again is to sample
from the distribution that we get after
measuring this final state in the
standard basis let's say
so depending on the type of noise
present this task
can be classified into two regimes what
are these two regions
the fast regime is when the strength of
the noise is really low
let's say the strength is some constant
divided by the number of qubits I call
this the low noise bridging
and the second regime that I will talk
about
is when the strength of the noise is
high it's a constant for each of the
gates that you saw
what happens in the low noise regime
once again to recap this is a regime
when the strength of the noise is some
constant divided by the number of qubits
there are results which say that if we
are in the low noise regime then all of
the noise present in our system can be
approximated by a global depolarizing
noise Channel at the very end
thank you
that means that the final state of the
system can be written
in terms of like a global depolarizing
Channel this is the noiseless component
and this is like the noisy component the
maximally mixed and the pre-factor that
you have the strength of This Global
depolarizing Channel
is something like this Epsilon here is
the strength of each of the local noise
channels and S is the size of the
circuit so in some sense you squeeze out
all the local noise that's present in
your circuit and try to like write it at
the very end as a global depolarizing
set
oh by the way feel free to stop me with
questions
however the low noise freaking is not
satisfactory uh like in terms of being a
practical model for practical random
circuit something why
well first of all
experiments are finite size systems
whereas
these hardness results
or for example these approximations that
we saw of the loan isolation let's say
these are complexity theoretic
statements in the limit of a large
number of cubits so we are talking about
scaling up these demonstrations in some
sense
and when we are scaling our devices up
the assumption that the noise would go
down with the number of qubits that does
not sound too realistic
a more realistic model would be modeling
the noise as having a constant noise
strength
and ah and so for fault tolerance having
noise to be a constant suffices
we know that these threshold theorems
tell us that if we have noise up to a
certain constant then we can just do
fault tolerance and
get like
uh
and get the full power of quantum
computing
this brings us to the high noise raising
this is when the noise strength is a
constant
like I said
this seems to be much more realistic in
terms of a model of like what's really
happening in Hardware
thank you
now if the noise that we have in
Hardware is only depolarizing noise
then we have results like that say that
the system tends to the maximally mixed
it
and it tends to the maximally mixed it
pretty fast in depth
this means that it's classically
like these distributions become
classically sample up to whatever
inverse polynomial Precision we want
after poly log depth or Beyond
so what happens for log depth
there was a landmark result recently
which says that the same intuition is
true for log depth as well
we can classically sample from a
distribution that's close to like one
over poly Precision no matter what the
polynomial is we can choose the
polynomial and
and this paper gives a classical sampler
which samples from random Quantum
circuits in this regime with the
depolarizing noise of a constant noise
any questions up to here
okay
then let me move on to the next slide
when I will talk about types of noise
present in real Hardware
and the motivation is something of the
following form
depolarizing is just one of the many
types of noises present in real Hardware
unital noise is generalized depolarizing
so this family of noise channels are
similar in the sense that they are all
trying to scramble the system
entropy goes up when you have these
types of noise sounds
but like I said there's also one other
type of noise Channel present in real
Hardware
non-unital noises
they are very much like they're very
dissimilar to depolarizing
and they try to like reverse the
scrambling phenomenon that these
depolarizing type noise channels have
for example all real Hardware
has T1 decays and readout noise as well
if there's someone from any of these
companies here I think Ben Ben is from
Google so I presume Google software also
has T1 and readout error and these
non-unitable effects and sometimes they
are even dominant
entropy decreases when you have let's
say this family of noise channels
noise that you have after each gate so
each gate is biased towards a certain
pure state
and that's the T1 degree
so one model of these types of noises is
like this damping noise
you can think of it as a qubit reset
type noise it resets your qubit to the
zero state with some probability
so this model is T1 Decay as well
so what happens in the high noise regime
now
when both of these types of noises are
present
amplitude damping and depolarizing
so depolarizing tries to scramble the
distribution like we saw
now when we have those layers of random
Gates
they try to scramble the distribution
too
amplitude damping though tries to like
make the distribution tend towards a
fixed State like a pure state
unscramble the distribution that is
so there's a fight between these two
phenomena
which seem complementary
so who wins this fight
I mean regardless of who wins it sounds
like the lxcb score loses right yeah
[Music]
true that's true
what we show is that the damping noises
seem to be victorious
that's the highlight of our results
what do we mean by this formally
mathematically
anti-concentration is one property that
we study for these distributions of
random circuits what is that
so that's like a flatness property in
some sense that's trying to feel how
flat the distribution is if it's
catastrophically flat then we have this
classical samples
so how do we measure this so there are
two standard definitions
one is in terms of collision
probabilities if this is low this just
means that the distribution is kind of
flat
and the second is measuring like a
typical probability like looking at a
typical probability and trying to say
that's sufficiently large
for a flat distribution most of the
typical probabilities for these strings
will be pretty large
and in some cases
the first definition of collision
probability implies the second one so
that's stronger in some sense
all cases don't like do not have this
relation though
and for non-enutal noises this relation
breaks
either way what do we show
we show that when you have a constant
like a constant strength of both of
these noises
then neither of these definitions are
satisfied the distribution is not flat
at all
this is true no matter the depth of the
circuit
and this is true no matter what strength
of depolarizing noise is present in the
circuit
budding lets have full strength
depolarizing that's like the weird case
so whenever you have this damping or
qubit reset type noise
you never have this flatness property
what does this mean
well uh current results to show hardness
of random certificate sampling are
believed to require some sort of a
flatness property for the distribution
so these results break
so we do not know that sampling from
classically sampling from this
distributions up to certain precisions
that we knew for the noiseless case we
do not know if for those precisions
like classical is sampling from these
distributions is hard
then can we actually classically sample
from these distributions by the Samplers
we know from before
no because they also need a like a
catastrophically flatness like they need
the distribution to be catastrophically
flat as well
and since that is not satisfied
the the known classical Samplers they
break as well none of them work
then uh what does this mean
well one question that I leave to the
crowd here is does it mean that we have
some Quantum signal in these
distributions
can the presence of non-newnital noise
indicate that maybe there's a way to get
noisy
scalable quantum
like a noisy scalable Quantum speed up
demonstration
to motivate this question further in the
worst case at least
we know that non-hignital noises
can sometimes be a resource in Quantum
computing for example there was a
Quantum refrigerator paper from
some years back which studied something
very similar
and that's all thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
I want to understand uh actually the
question both to you and physicists in
the audience how important or
non-unitive
noises in nature from the point of view
of how surprising would it be to to have
a system in which non-unital noise could
be essentially completely ignored
uh so my perspective is that uh right
now at least we do not know how to
suppress the levels of non-imital noise
like are too well so there's still
constant non-imital noise after every
kid and let's imagine
physical system
right so I my hand says that are
non-evident noises are probably
fundamental but I would let a physicist
speak I think I I don't have a good good
handle on that's the physics perspective
yeah okay so for that you need feedback
so nature is not
natural I would say but immune system
s
not just the noise trailer
the fixed points
we all have too many systems which have
that I mean you don't you probably won't
have many systems whose fixed point is
just maximally an extent I mean
non-uneral noise seems kind of like a
systematic error or your systematic bias
and you'd expect that in many
experiments when you notice those you
would just fix them right and thereby
reduce the noise to being Universal
if it is
fixed points should be the maximally
mixed state it seems uh
unnatural yeah natural to me
maybe we'll take further questions okay
yeah
[Applause]
yes
right here
I don't have any I don't have any fancy
slides I actually don't have any results
to present either it's just kind of open
and open problem I thought this was an
open problem session I didn't realize
this was like uh talked about your
results session it is maybe okay so just
something I've been thinking about and I
thought I'll pose these questions also
it should be discussion based on at
least yeah interrupt ask me questions
uh it's gonna be short
um okay so I was just thinking about
these computational problems that we
that we often encounter where the input
to the problem is a Quantum state so you
know like a traditional computer science
textbooks will have these problems where
the input is in that string and output
is whatever maybe it's an ended string
maybe it's a one bit thing it's a
decision problem but just think about
problems where they this is a terrible
marker
um
but the input is a Quantum state
yeah
so the input is either
State row and maybe you get many copies
of it and the goal of the problem is
often to minimize the number of copies
used you're trying to minimize the
sample complexity and give you some
examples
of these problems you know things like I
guess tomography would be a classical
classic example
photography
but then there's variants of tomography
like Shadow tomography that we
all know and love
um
but yeah you can think of many different
examples there's like this Quantum pack
learning you can
um you know trying to learn properties
of like like these these could be some
special States like like row could be
the give state of hamiltonian I know you
learned the hamiltonian from it and
these questions are often phrased like
this you have input as input some pure
State cat's eye or maybe a mixtape rope
and you want to figure something out
about this learns and property computers
and property and you want to minimize
the sample complexity so you want to
minimize number of copies of K and then
of course you also want your algorithm
to be efficiency you also want time
complexity small
okay so this is a nice abstraction for
many many problems
but okay what I'm asking is where does
the state come from
so
you know if you have your uh on a
complexity Theory hat on maybe you're
thinking like you know maybe the state
comes from approver or something comes
from something outside your control and
then this is a perfectly good
abstraction to the situation you just
have copies of the state and then that's
all you really have there's nothing more
to be done but let's put like let's put
our algorithms hat on like you're
somebody who's trying to do algorithms
and this state might come from a
previous part of your own algorithm
right so let me give you an example of
what might happen let's say you want to
do Shadow tomography
and you want to do so so you had a
previous Quantum algorithm that
um maybe was doing some kind of very
difficult chemistry or Material Science
simulation with a lot of effort you
prepared the ground state
um maybe it's pure maybe it's ketzai and
you want to do something something like
Shadow tomorrow you want to learn many
observables of your ground state so you
want to compute maybe like N squared
different observables you know some two
point correlators or some some a bunch
of observables that you're interested in
because of whatever application
now what I'm saying is that maybe this
is not the right abstraction that you
just have copies of the state because in
fact you have the source code that
prepared the state right you you were
the one who prepared the state on your
own quantum computer and then you went
ahead and you just
you know went too abstract and you just
like threw away the fact that you were
the one who created the state and just
said well I have copies of catsai and
let's just go from here and do Shadow
tomography on it
so
um so yeah so depending on the scenario
you're in uh you may or may not have
access to the source code for the state
you're preparing but if you do you can
often do
you can do better things right so so in
particular if I have the source code for
size so what I mean by the source for
quetza is like some kind of quantum
circuit you have a description explicit
description of every gate and so you
have some you know unitary like this you
your full gate decomposition when you
put in some canonical starting State
maybe all zero you you literally get our
catch PSI and as before we're trying to
minimize the number of copies of PSI
because this state was really hard to
prepare that's that's why we're trying
to minimize our sample complexity even
originally the intuition is the state is
hard to prepare you want to use ask your
copies and here again the state is hard
to prepare which which translates to
this unitary is hard in the sense that
uses a lot of gauge so again we want to
use very few uses of this unitary
but you can do more than just prepare
ketsai from this unit so some examples
of things you could do or for example
once you have this unitary like you have
an explicit list of all these Gates uh
let me call this usai
from your site you can also do for
example control USI
which is just take every single gate
here and make a controlled version its
gate complexity is going to be the same
again so you should morally think of
this operator as also having the same
cost as you sign like if this had G
Gates this is going to happen
G Gates or something so this should also
be in this model where we're thinking
that creating catsai costs some amount
this is roughly costs the same amount
another thing you can do is the inverse
operation
and you could also do even more exotic
things like you could do the unitary
that creates the the complex conjugate
of PSI for example so you take every
single gate in your circuit and you
complex conjugate it
um
okay so I guess what I'm saying is
having the full source code of the of
preparing catsai gives you access to
other operations and these other
operations can actually help you can
solve certain tasks faster when you have
them then when you just have copies of
the state so let me give you an example
of such a thing
um
yeah
so say you just want to do a full State
tomography on a one qubit state so I
have a one qubit state
foreign
and if I just have copies of
um copies of site oh sorry I want to
learn a one qubit state to error Epsilon
let's say to trace distance
if I only have copies of PSI it's a one
qubit state how many how many copies of
PSI do I need to learn to trace distance
anyone know how to stop their head
shout out some answers something will be
right there's not that many options
squared
and you want to write down a classical
you know to a vector over two numbers
such that the vector written down this
place distance Epsilon to the actual
state
uh but then with those controlled things
it's going to become whatever Epsilon
yes sir now I'm gonna call that full
source code like if I have the source
code which means I can do you know this
guy I can do the inverse and so on then
in fact it becomes
it becomes better you can do it with
water Epsilon and this is essentially
the amplitude application
it's not super surprising if you
here's a fun question what if I only
give you
the ability to apply use I but I don't
give you inverses okay code you can just
apply the unitary forward
where are you are you here or here
It's gotta be one of these two because
this is strictly in between right so
once you have the inventory of course
you can create copies so this is
certainly if you do this and
source code includes a special message
so let's unboxing one represent and it
works for one represent squared versions
squared and somebody has any words in
the middle anyway
um okay yeah so it turns out that this
is
using only forward copies
which is kind of surprising to me
um
anyways to the point of like so this is
just an example but I'm not pitching any
specific open problem but maybe I'm
pitching a research detection which is
to take all of the problems that we have
already studied in Quantum Computing
where we have copies of the status input
and release like study them again with
this model where you actually have the
source code available and for some of
them I think we'll be able to get speed
ups and if these tasks these These are
used as submarines in an actual
algorithm then they do have available
resources so you'll get actual speedups
like this this motivating example that I
had that maybe you created a state there
was a ground straight up some difficult
chemistry molecule whatever you wanted
to do Shadow tomography you want to
learn a lot of observables so now if you
have a faster Shadow tomography
algorithm in the source code model
you'll get a better algorithm for this
uh chemistry problem that I was
motivating
um yeah anyway that's all I wanted to
pitch so any questions or does anyone
have any other examples of situations
where you genuinely have the state but
you don't have the source code
you just get a note just a contrast like
why you would be in that situation then
yeah all right and also open discussion
yeah a few minutes
I finished what I want to say in less
than 10 minutes yeah okay
um I was wondering if you could give
some high level intuition for why having
the unitary allows me to achieve the
faster or the better rate than having
comments
um
yeah if it's the intuition is that um
you can apply the unitary over and over
again so you can take small differences
and magnify them by applying it over and
over again that's kind of the short
version but if you think of your unitary
as being a small rotation by Epsilon if
I just gave you the ability to measure
that state you would kind of need one
wraps around Square copies to figure out
what the Epsilon is
um
but if you could keep applying the
unitary you can keep rotating until you
rotate by you know 90 degrees divided by
Epsilon and now you've gone all the way
to an orthogonal state from what you
started
that's kind of the intuitive version the
more General result here is just that
you can learn any unitary any d by D
unitary
um given copies of given the ability of
the unitary only in the forward
Direction was ordered D Squared over
Epsilon
uses of
DSi and this is type
you need exactly this number of users
and you can also do it with this number
of users of only the forward unitary not
the
London flow source code strength
do you have any examples where the
complex conjugated does something no I
don't have an example for it it helps a
lot although yesterday William told me
there's an example
and some of these like Bell sampling
things you can uh get slightly better
sample complexities if you have a state
and it's complex conjugate
thank you
also be creating for the source but I
don't think this is an exhaustive list
of what they do like one thing you can
do is with search where you can create
the following State
because once maybe this follows from
having a control operation actually
anyway but you can do things maybe that
I haven't imagined in these three
examples again down here
yeah so I think if your state is
produced through a load that circuit
with a measurement but you are not
allowed to extend the depths of the
search then if that's an area of
temperature cannot have a given their
comparison
but rather you want to have copies
I mean you have a low tax unit that's a
unit no lab circuit a comparison State
okay but this uh certainly will some say
mid-circuit measurement and
yeah if you want to have a unit or like
pure unitary that prepares this state
and you will need to do amplitude
amplification and that requires
extending the circuit that but if you're
limiting the certain death sentence
coherently and
um for example you can ask what does the
source code for PSI would mean and what
I mean for that is you prepare
purification where you trace out some
qubits and then you get PSI so if you
have a circuit which prepared some State
cat's eye which had a bunch of
measurements you could one thing you
could do is just sorry I mean like
there's some successful probability like
what you need to amplify that
is
maybe there's some circuit with some
very tiny probability produces catch I
okay or rows and we posted like another
right yeah
that's right okay yeah because that
could be an example do you post selected
an extremely unlikely event
another setting I can imagine is one
where you have partial information
yes calibrate engage Some Noise then you
know what to introduce you and
reasonably well whatever but you don't
know some other ones
so I guess that feels like in between
the two sentences right do you think
like noise right so like you have a idea
of what you were trying to do but then
there's this noise which is outside of
your control and so you can't really
you don't really have the source code
yeah
yeah so I think the model where you do
have to just assume you have copies of
row is certainly well motivated
especially outside of algorithmic
context
but um I haven't seen too much of a
systematic study of like what happens
when you do have access
any other questions comments thoughts
how's that
funny in general if you know an
eigenvector of this eye you can grow
from this site
well if you have
you're saying yeah
you have an explicit
this oh sorry that was your third oh
that's the third thing yeah yeah this is
I should maybe drop box around it what I
mean is you just have the ability to
apply you can say as a box but you can't
you can look at it
this was kind of surprising to me the
source Court thing is it's just so this
is this is without the source yes this
is without the source so this is where
you're like you just have a black box
um
it's a special case of this result which
is that you can just learning unitary
using D Squared over Epsilon uses of the
unit as a black box and then well this
is a one Cube at stake so the over there
has a D Squared
yes that's
um and this
this is a result that we had earlier
this year
is
Ryan O'Donnell
it's called
topical tomography of unitary sometimes
um
and I mean maybe one of the main reasons
why you would only have the state and
not have these unitaries is that someone
only wants you in that mistake right as
in Quantum money as in copy protected
Quantum software right I mean it's like
okay you know we we a lot of uh
cryptographic functionality is based on
the limitations of quantum measurement
right it's like if I just give you usai
then you know by using it enough times
you can recover all of sides all of that
goes away then yeah yeah that's that's
definitely so yeah crypto motivated
applications it's very reasonable to
just have problems
also makes the U.S Implement their
architecture so when you actually
Implement your audio
polynomials
but in this scenario you imagine
somebody else has a quantum computer
creates cats eye on it and then
transfers the quantum State you might
want to review so now we have to like
have two different ones we just talk to
each other
the Quantum Internet or something
all they say is
a physical process
foreign
yeah
or maybe it's not really a quantum
computer at all there's like some kind
of actual physical device that just
criminalizes and rows the dipstick so
yeah certainly that could be
situation
but uh yeah
for actually for algorithms that people
want to do on things like yeah
people really do want to bike out of
demography or classical shadows and so
on and all of them have Epsilon
dependencies that are far worse than one
of Epsilon Shadow tomography has Epsilon
number four I think in the denominator
and classical electron squared maybe you
can improve them
so when you have the whole source code
uh what techniques would you use to to
show a lower bound if any and and and
and in particular like is there a lower
bound of one over Epsilon
for this problem if any of the whole
sources
kind of hard
Ness
yeah
lower back like for example in this
setting we assume you have black box
access to you so that new people going
on because you can see Oracle where you
can place
even with source code like one partial
thing you can do is just give yourself
access to all of these guys black boxes
and then through lower bars okay
creating complexity arguments or
Communications
I don't know what techniques you can use
if you genuinely have a source code that
seems too hard because
so
I don't even know
let's read the name of the game
like the point is depending on the
product if you're doing like somehow
they
very simple circuit already gives the
answer
right right but you could have like some
kind of very obfuscular way of creating
a state
but then it's very first Chrome
dependent right what's the exact
certification improving your balance in
the source code model will depending on
how the source comes
you might have to just go ahead and give
yourself Black Box access to a few
things that can be derived from us
do you expect this separation or need to
be polynomial or
you know
would that be much larger definition yes
I don't know in general but for just
this question of which source code can
you get more than about one mosquito but
I think one thing that can be shown is
if you only have
um for example
the ability to create so
if you yeah
it's the only thing you have is the
ability to reflect about PSI so most of
these algorithms often the thing we use
isability reflective outside I think you
have only the ability to reflect about
PSI any algorithm that uses this
reflection operator like K times I think
you can convert an album that uses only
copies of size and this is K squared of
them so like most have a quadratic speed
up if the only property using is a
reflection property
but I don't know what happens
is
that the same thing
I no I don't know how to deal with
the unity in general the thing with the
reflection that's nice is it's fully
specified
the reflection is just on site for
surface I might just want everybody else
it does last one the unitary could do
other things elsewhere so you have to
argue that
is not able to use that other fact
whatever it's doing on the rest of the
outer space on the other hand it cannot
depend on which is
size so it's possible one should be able
to extend these lower bonds to the
setting as well
I'm not sure
thank you
it's a black folks access to you say is
sufficient to construct or approximate
new PSI inverse by the inverse
entire instructions
I'm not
doesn't this allow one to actually do
black box constructions and controlling
yourself
inverse is definitely possible
that's right are you asking a given
access to you without any knowledge as a
black box you can construct control you
yes no it's a proven it's a proven thing
but you can construct with black box
access you can construct new inverse
no that's right generally
yeah because like there's these classic
old questions like inverting a
permutation which has an exponential
about it and that's exactly a question
at this point you have access to
negative in One Direction yeah it's just
you can do it but it's not official yes
right that's probably true
I'm a DS illness based Dimension
that's like D Squared real I mean
numbers to describing it right okay I
think a comeback saying this is another
way of showing them
[Music]
I'm not sure
yeah I mean so it's possible again some
quality over Epsilon using other
techniques like for example
um
actually I'm not sure
I don't know maybe it's still possible
you know the thing of you did you sign
you applying to half of a maximum
entangled pair and then you just do full
step right and this will give you
something here's not D Squared though
it'll be worse yeah
foreign
[Laughter]
um
[Music]
it's like
well I think they're even trying to get
like
information
and um
oh
it's pure because
[Music]
right now
oh
you don't get an improvement in the
dimension defense
like maybe there's always a generics
it's kind of subtle because sometimes
you need both the inverse and the
forward directions sometimes you only
need the forward directions
thank you
okay
I think
that's right yeah
I guess I'm happy just
horrible
oh yeah
reviews
foreign
[Music]
yeah yeah
I don't know that's not the kind of
thing usually let's see what you want is
like yeah
this extra foreign
foreign
I don't know
yes in general
it's still true that with the sources
[Music]
right right I'm saying even in the
general details if you give me if you
end your University
besides all
because like right because you don't
know anything about it yeah
[Music]
at first I was like this is true
thing to do
it
right yeah
and this might still be better
go learn the entire universe because you
only pay a D Squared penalty but your
Epsilon so facility to the 12 algorithm
whereas if you did like say demography
that would give you the 20.
[Music]
yeah
that's something
um
and so every stage of the algorithm you
have stronger and stronger barriers of
how close
so we start from an album that learns a
Unity
most of us
I literally know nothing about it
no it encompasses
substance
[Music]
thank you
foreign
of course
operations
you just have to have some procedure
is
universally focusing without exactly yes
well maybe
um
brokers
difficult
IES
also this is I guess
um
you can't Implement control units
entry
yes
um
is
what happens
it was wonderful to meet you yeah
there's no General
students
so
yeah yeah
thank you
I posted this video
next from what and of course
later but
victim
s
foreign
I'm not sure
okay
I guess they're saying that if you know
the super operator
and it's basically the decision
this is something I think yeah
Little Things
course
[Applause]
it's just the task
acceptable
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
anyone
foreign
that simulate uh the experimental
gaussian button sampling by ustc and
Xanadu and I'm happy to talk about the
details but due to the time limit I'm
gonna I made this slide really high
level so I'm I'm more than happy to talk
about the details offline and also you
can find the details from this paper and
before I uh begin I just want to thank
the all the collaborators minzao and
Yuri from Argo National Lab and also
Bill and also my advisor Liam
okay so over the last five years we have
seen this first Quantum Advantage claims
first by Google using random circuit
sampling and also ustc and Xanadu are
using gaussian version sampling and they
claim that uh for Clash of computer it's
going to be really hard to simulate
their their experiment that means in a
reasonable time and reasonable
computational resources
but we have to keep in mind that these
kind of experiments are really noisy so
that means there can be a way to make uh
take advantage of this noise noisy
nature to to invent a class algorithm
that can simulate those experiments much
much more efficiently than they expected
so that's going to be the motivation of
our work and we show that we can
simulate This gaussian Modern sampling
type of experiment using our new New
Classic algorithm
okay
so before I talk about this our new
result I just want to briefly talk about
what Photon sampling is
um so Photon sampling was proposed by a
Scott and also Alex archipov this
setting is really simple in in principle
you just generate n single photons and
then you just put them in beam splitter
circuits so typically this beam Source
circuit is just a layer of many beam
splitter and then this after this
buttons going through this stream
Twitter they constitute large amount of
interference between them and then we
eventually measure the output photon
number pattern then using the the
hardness of computing the alpha
probability of such a circuit uh Scott
and Alex archipel proved that uh
simulating simulating this circuit is uh
hard for classical computer under some
conjectures
but and then after this proposal many
experimentalists try to to implement
such an experiment but it turns out that
it was really challenging because
generating and this large number of
single photons was really hard the main
main reason is that the current
technique to generate a single photon is
mostly a probabilistic so that means if
you want to generate like 100 photons
then we have to wait a very long time to
to see this uh all 100 photons at the
same time so that means uh this foxtape
wooden sampling is quite hard so that
made people to change the problem
slightly so instead of talking about Fox
state or single Photon input State
people started to talk about gaussian
state or more specific more specifically
screen state I'm not going to talk about
the details of this key state but this
is basically a certain type of position
of photon numbers and which has has been
started a lot in in Quantum Optics
Community theoretically and also
experimentally
and what's good of this key state is
that we can generate uh this state
deterministically so that's why people
start to choose this uh this setup to
demonstrate Quantum advantage in an
optical platform
and other mathematics are just uh logic
goes similarly so just using the
hardness of of computing the output
probability we we also show that the
hardness so the hardness of simulating
such a circuit
okay so uh and then this using gaussian
modern sampling many experimental groups
uh started to implement this this
experiment and what is the goal real
goal of this experiment the goal is that
first of all we have this hardness
result so that means for noiseless cases
we don't expect there a class algorithm
that simulates this uh this noiseless
quotient sampling in a polynomial time
that means asymptotic policies is hard
to simulate but this this is not the
case for this near-term devices we know
that these Neutron devices have a lot of
loss or noise so that means we we should
not focus on this asymptotic scaling but
we have to focus on certain finite size
uh for certain finite size kind of
Advantage because of this noise so why
is that so the reason is if we just uh
without correcting the error we just
increase the system size then of course
the noise will accumulate in your system
and everything you measure is going to
be noise without any instead of any
interesting Quantum signal so that's why
we have to focus on instead of talking
about asymptotic scaling of using these
nisk devices we have to focus on the
certain size finite size Quantum
advantage
so but still you have to have a large
enough system size that leads to this
Goldilocks regime that means system size
has to be big enough for classical
computer to big enough to to heart for
classical computer and at the same time
not too big for noise to dominate the
system
so that means we have to find this
Goldilocks regime and to find this to
find this regime we need to understand
how well the best classic algorithm can
do to take advantage of this noise
and I said this is a uh it can be
possibly um like inefficient and that's
fine because even these music devices
are cannot scale up so classical
computer kind of algorithm can be also
inefficient in this sense
and so with this goal people are
starting to implement this gaussian
button sampling from ustc and Xanadu and
they reported some numbers so the first
number is the the output average photo
number so they claim that they have
detected over then 100 photons on
average
and the loss rate was uh 50.5 to 0.7
that means 50 to 70 percent of info
Photon get lost in the circuit
and finally they claim that I would take
uh at least 100 years for classical
computer to generate even a single
single sample
so that was the claim of this experiment
and uh what what is this number this 100
years this is from this the best known
classical algorithm we had at that time
so this best known class algorithm is
simply just based on this chain this
Computing the marginal and use this
conditional probability to sample this
one by one so that means the the cost
the main cost of this the best known
place called algorithm we had was
Computing the output probability
and we know that this Computing will
probably increases exponentially at the
complexity of computing the up
probability uh exponentially increases
as the output bottom number and that was
the reason why uh expenses really
focused on increasing the alpha proton
number uh even though the loss rate was
really hard high
but the serious caveat of this estimate
is that this best known class algorithm
they use
did not take advantage of any loss and
noise so this is uh it can be this
number this or at least 100 years this
can be misleading because we are not
really we didn't really use the the main
characteristic of this this experiment
so then how can we really use this noisy
nature of this experiment so we first
need to understand what noise really
affects on the system and typically we
know that this uncorrective noise often
a transform or Quantum State you have
into a classical State I mean that's
easy to simulate especially as the
system size scales
so for example for random circuit
sampling uh with a depolarizing noise we
know that if we just simply scale up
with uh with this defloration noise with
a sufficiently large depth then we know
that uh eventually the output state is
going to be close to a maximally mixed
state that means we don't have any much
uh interesting signal from the output
state
but this is a synthetic statement and
the current experiment is not in a
synthetic regime and the current RCS
experiment random circuit sampling
experiments output State it's not
believed to be sufficiently close to
maximally mixed state so that was the
reason why we believe that they claim
that this uh simulating that their
experiment is hard
and and the same logic just goes in this
gaussian modern sampling setup we first
with a slight a change of this physics
but uh so for the gaussian modern
sampling case the most detrimental noise
is a photon loss and this Photon loss
um if you have this Photon loss and just
scale up the system size then it's going
to this paper showed that the output
state of this Photon sampling circuit
will converge to a so-called thermal
state so I'm not going to talk about the
details of this normal state but you can
just think of it as some maximally
mixtape type in in button sampling case
which can be easily simulable using
classically
so the same same logic here so for
gaussian version sampling the everything
is going to be easy eventually
but uh similarly uh to random circuit
sampling the current gaussian button
sampling outcome state is uh believed to
be still a far from Summer State so this
summer States this trivial approximation
is not going to work well
yeah
oh yeah yeah
uh
[Music]
yeah we know uh we know some scaling but
uh I'm not going to talk to the details
but I can find more details offline
yeah
you're assuming here that uh you say
it's believed to be observed in far from
natural mixtape and he said this is
because
the samples are small and also here
right is this is this the reason oh I
mean I mean it could be the noise is not
what you're
yeah that's that's true yeah I mean this
is the latest high level concept that we
we are not in the regime where they
convert noise is so dominant that
everything goes into just like some
fixed point of the noise
yeah I mean like as Tony said the the
noise type can be different so uniform
it might not be the best for this week
what I'm saying is we don't um
uh just high level ideas like this this
finite system so it could be the case
that the noises have not has not
dominated yet
uh yeah so
but gaussian modern sampling case the
approximation was uh the fixed point was
Summers hate and again this is finite
side system so we don't think that the
output state is really close to the
summer stage
so this trivial algorithm does sampling
from this fixed point is not going to
work to simulate this current current
experiment like RCS and GBS
so our question was basically can we do
better than this point uh algorithm
this is the algorithm a slide and it has
a really high level ideas that uh I can
talk more details in offline but this is
a typically a typical gaussian modern
sampling circuit with a with Photon loss
so you just prepare some gaussian State
and then they go through the stream
speeder circuit and while many photons
get lost during the circuit and then
finally we measure the alpha Photon of
the output state
and what we found is that we can rewrite
this circuit as follows we have a two
different parts here the fourth part the
first part is basically some space tape
and beam splitter circuit that means
this is still a gaussian buttons I'm
playing with the perfect uh a perfect
value sampling that means there is no
loss in the in this circuit and then
there is the second part which is a
noise circuit a noise channel so this is
basically a it has a class called a
description so this is basically really
a classical that means the hardness has
to come from only from the first part
and the second part cannot increase the
complexity uh intuitively speaking
so this is really General picture you
can find any
where
maybe a hard computational task to
figure out what's important
here so finding finding the right hand
side yeah yeah that's that that's easy
so we found the the system uh the
program that can yeah they can find this
yeah so
so what's interesting here is that there
is two contributions for the output
photons one is that this first part is
purely Quantum part that output photons
and at the same time this pressure part
also outputs photons
so what it implies is that not all the
output points are purely Quantum and
many of them can be just classical
photons which can be actually easily
similar simulated
so why uh this is important because then
we can just focus on simulating the
first part and the second part because
second part is really easy to simulate
I mean
it has a classical description
um
in the probability Theory like trade
space method
like laser is like not quantum
sorry
yeah yeah exactly accordingly yes
okay so then like how powerful this
method is in in experiment we found that
after using uh using this experimental
parameter we found that only three to
seven percent of photons actually from
the first part and over the 90 of what
from the second part so the F over the
ninety percent of photons are actually
classical and we can just see uh so the
task is the simulated this small portion
of discuss important sampling part
so our strategy is to simulate this
Circuit by using a tensor Network
algorithm
this is approximate simulation because
we have to truncate some part
and the reason why we use this is uh
this uh motivated by the solar cell
approximation in the sense that if we
just set this first part to be very
trivial state which is a vacuum state
that means zero Photon State then that
this is exactly the the strategy of
approximating by thermostats so that's
why we say this is a generalization of
distribute thermostat approximation
and we use this algorithm to simulate uh
this calcium modern sampling experiment
and the problem is how to verify that
our algorithm is better than experiment
so of course if we can compute the
Toleration distance then this is easy
but Computing this quantity itself is
too hard this is a computational and
also hard and also we need a lot of
exponentially main example from
experiment so this is not a good good
way so what uh example is typically do
is to just use many as many uh many
benchmarking methods to rule out all
possible Markov distribution they can
people can come up with
so they have a use some like xav type
and other other type of benchmarkings
but it turns out that uh like Ben and
this Google team has uh was able to
spoof all this benchmarking except for
this uh high order correlation function
here higher population function is
basically the marginal
property of this output samples
so that means so this is a problematic
because we don't know which one uh we
don't know Google is better or
experiment is better uh in the sense of
tvt so what but for our case we show
that we can beat this benchmarking as
well including all possible all other
Benchmark things so that was that is the
main result
and I'm not gonna go uh through all the
numerical results but I'm gonna just
show this this a high order correlation
function and then I'm gonna finish this
so
uh so this is this y-axis is basically
some some score so the larger the better
and this x-axis is the the marginal mode
you are going to select to compute this
correlation function and then we can you
can see that all these uh over up to
this sixth order which is the largest
order that was calculated in experiment
uh for as an Evidence of a Quantum
Advantage we do not observe any a clear
Advantage from experiment over our class
algorithm so that means uh all the
benchmarking experimentalists provided
can be ruled out uh from by our class
algorithm
and also the important thing is like how
much computational cost we have used and
so we have used only one hour
computation time but we use like 300
gpus to compute to to sample from this
MPS at this tensor Network method
so the conclusion is we invented a class
algorithm that uses tensor Network which
can simulate the state of the art uh
gaussian modern sampling experiments
and what the implication is that for the
future experiment towards Quantum
computational Advantage they have to
focus on decreased loss rates instead of
uh focusing on increasing the upper
bottom number because there was the main
focus of experiment as I said in the
first slide first few slides but uh we
characterize that that's not the the
main computational cost but there is a
loss has to really controlled well
for example what's interesting is that
uscc are also implemented experiment in
2023 to increase the upper photo number
but it turns out that new experiments is
easier than the previous experiment 20
21st from the same group so that means
they are targeting a wrong uh wrong
figure married and so they have to the
reason was the new experiment has a
larger loss rate than the previous
previous experiment So based on our
algorithm we can finally characterize
what is the most important like quantity
to boost the quantum Advantage so that's
the result and thank you very much for
your time
[Applause]
okay yeah so you didn't explain at all
what why you could talk much like this
with an NPR so what is the what was the
ID of oh yeah I mean the basic idea is
the average composition
now you have a very small number of
photons so then then second one you can
have is limited so that's why we can use
them this is like a locality is it like
in the usual the fact that there's a
limited is going to be the one but the
main idea is that just like think about
just you have a single button then the
amount of entanglement you can generate
can be it's only very very small so that
that is the main main idea of the
oh so after the composition you have a
very small total number so then if they
would change the geometry of the ozone
sampling setup all right right
your quality of whatever right in this
case uh so there was some like normal
like non-local property in a circuit but
that was fine because entangled model
was not very large the usdc experiments
are all too old yeah that was almost
around them but it's only less than 10
photons so it doesn't matter what where
you organize it the entertainment is
really bounded
okay yeah let's let's keep going
[Applause]
something
true
awesome
okay
[Music]
um
I want to talk about not so much a
result also but more of some heuristic
idea that we have if at the end of the
talk that idea is broken you would all
make me very happy
and and this is work together with
Michael gullins and David Cross and but
it also Builds on a lot of discussions
I've had in the last year
Alex and Alex and Robbie and Bill and
lots of people
um right so what's the question the
question
um we're asking is
um one that Scott has raised in last
year's talk in this year's talk again
can you hide a secret somehow in the
output distribution of a Quantum circuit
in a way that's efficiently checkable so
can you design a Quantum circuit
Quantum circuit C which somehow depends
on a secret string s
such that now now here comes the setting
um as a classical verifier I can give
that Quantum circuit to some Quantum
prover the quantum prover is going to
run the circuit on this quantum computer
sample from the output distribution and
send the samples back to the classical
verifier
then the classical verifier will do some
sort of decoding some checking of the
samples which is efficient
and what I'm going to require is that
the verify accepts an honest quantum
proofer but reject any classical proof
so if something here is non-quantum they
will reject okay notice that this is
much weaker than requiring that the
samples are actually sampled from the
correct distribution
okay we've seen one very prominent
example of this type by Mick Bremner and
Dan Shepard back in 2019 they designed
some iqp circuits based on quadratic
residue codes
and they conjecture that
um checking some specific property of
the output distribution of those
circuits would be something that's
classically hard
okay unfortunately Greg Meyer well
unfortunately I don't know Greg Meyer
who we've heard this morning in 2019
um coded this up and found that this can
actually be broken in polynomial time
okay so here we are we don't
um have any really really any candidate
for such a scheme at this point and
Robbie has been very active
um coming up with ideas for such schemes
and breaking them again
so what I'm going to present to you
today is the first idea or well a idea
that we have which we haven't been able
to break it
which doesn't mean it can't be broken
and I hope you will all be able to break
it
okay so this is what I'm going to show
you a contraction based on iqp circuits
plus C not Gates
and the basic idea is we take an easy to
simulate circuit we encode it in a
circuit which looks like it's hard to
simulate
okay so here comes what we have at the
moment our cheating strategy at the
moment runs in time two to the log
squared n where n is the number of
qubits it's almost polynomial we don't
know how to make it polynomial so the
question at the end of this talk will be
can we make it just a little bit better
question so far is everyone happy with
the setting
is there a price well we don't have we
don't have a pizza price I can set a
pizza price
okay there's a pizza price
is increased longer those problems yes
where do we use the secret
like why is that a total content as a
product
approval okay a proof of bottom
bottomless protocol is a valid protocol
um but we want something that's a little
bit simpler that's not you know
involving an interaction and yeah we
want something that which is really just
I give you a circuit you sample from the
circuit we want to make it really
really which is why also we you know we
can't base it we haven't been able to
base it on any crypto Primitives
yeah okay ready for the construction and
let me introduce you to iqp degree three
circuits okay so the gate set is z Gates
control Z Gates and control Ctrl Z Gates
and the second which you can run in iqp
degree three three has a layer of hotter
mods then some diagonal circuit with
gates from the skate set and then a
layer of hotter once again
and then the task is sampling from the
distribution
okay we're going to keep track of the
gate locations in these well let me call
them tenses L1 L2 L3 and which does have
entries at you know an edge or a hyper
Edge
okay
now it turns out that the output
probability is output amplitudes of
these iqp circuits are given by gaps of
these Boolean functions which directly
correspond to the degree of the iqp
circuit so the Boolean function is just
one with linear coefficients R1
quadratic coefficients are two and
triplet coefficients of three
okay the important thing to observe is
that Z and control Z is a clever gate
czz is a non-clipper
okay Remnant montenario Shepard at
approximately something from these
circuits if I draw a random iqp circuit
or something that's classically
intractable up to a complexity
okay now what happens if we add C naught
Gates now we consider the same setup but
before we do the layer of other mods I
will add a layer of C naught Gates
any pair of qubits I'm allowed to add a
layer of scene objects how does that
change the circuit
turns out the Circuit Family of iqp
circuits is actually invariant under
this how do we see this well if I act
with C naught on some bit string like
some state in a computational basis
State I can just equivalently write this
as a linear action on the bitstream
right so I've seen a circuit composed of
C naught Gates is just described by this
n times n Matrix now right now two to
them by 2 to the N times n Matrix a
the Restriction that it's invertible
okay
good
so such an iqp circuit iqp plus C naught
circuit is actually equivalent to an iqp
circuit without seeing up Gates but
where I alter the coefficient by a
inverse a inverse tensor 2 a inverse
tensor 3. right so I think of these
coefficients as tensors right they have
legs and so now I'm just applying a
inverse on each of those
so far so simple
but maybe you can already see where this
is going I'm going to take a circuit of
this type with a d and c decomposition
I'm going to going to turn it into a
circuit of this type and the task is
going to be the find the decomposition
of that
okay
here's the construction okay so we take
linear and quadratic coefficients are 1
L2 uniformly at random I'm just going to
place ones and zeros randomly in The
Matrix or in this vector
I'm going to draw a random invertible
binary Matrix a
and then I'm going to take an L3 with
order log n menu t
log n menu one entries okay so it's a
log n sparse A3 tensor
okay now the scheme is I take the an A
or i b is this described by A1 l203 AE
is just this this Matrix and I'm going
to encode it well I'm going to do the
transformation that I showed you before
in multiplying by a inverse to come up
with this diagonal iqp circuit d a okay
then I'm going to send my new tensors
la123 to the proofer the proof is going
to run the iqp circuit sample and what
I'm going to do is I'm going to
calculate the xcb score
okay
now I can do that efficiently right why
because I only have log n many
non-clifford gates so I can use a
Clifford plus T simulator to simulate to
compute the probabilities
so far so far so good
okay
so that's a completeness of the protocol
well soundness is more complicated
question is can you efficiently spoof
the xcb given these La I tenses which
describe the iqp circuit
okay one sufficient condition which I'm
going to look at is can you efficiently
recover a matrix an invertible Matrix a
prime and a sparse tensor L3 Prime such
that you know this multiplied together
gives me L A3
and L3 Prime is login spots right
because then I would also have a method
um to simulate the circuit
good
so now I'm going to jump One Step M and
just tell you a fact namely that you can
efficiently and find an invertible
Matrix o
such that I can reduce this problem to a
minimization problem essentially over a
t times T size Matrix essentially binary
Matrix
right so you want to find
now a binary Matrix basically I've done
something similar to what William has
done right I've compressed all the
non-cliffidness somehow into a log n
Times log n corner of my Matrix
another task is to optimize over that
corner
okay so I want to optimize the entries
right the number of non-zero entries in
this new tensor such that I get
something which is order logarithm
but naively the runtime of that if I
search over all the matrixes is 2 to the
3T squared
log Square then
question is can you do better
yes okay for Supremacy purposes this is
more polynomial and exponential like a
practice right yes
second you're not going to get the sizes
where this is inhibited
I don't know I mean why not
like it's fair it's maybe I can see that
apt games that's all but simulating 80
Square tickets
[Applause]
there was a proper Learner in Williams
results
um no because the proper Learner in
Williams result would still use quantum
States right so I would be happy with
the approva you know preparing the state
than learning the circuit and then
I would be totally fine today if they
actually prepared the state somewhere in
between I would be happy
foreign
States
in his setup
I've had access to a Quantum State and
they said I'm here I'm just a classical
you know
classical person who has access to an
untrusted quantity computer also
okay
I feel like merging the previous talk
what happens if you got annoyed with
this if you've got the noise is going to
make this more complicated
think of this really not robust second
iqp sampling is not robust and this is
even at least less robust than those
right
I really don't know how
robust or robots
but if you find this x do you get a
circuit with t t gets with t squared to
you if you find an X such that in the
end you have right that
um the output of this of this algorithm
is going to be x times o
or X inverse times or inverse or so and
then all this multiplied together right
so then I have a circuit with other
login
so the bottleneck is finding the X not
simulating the circuit
right the bottleneck well I mean depends
on how you set it up right I mean
another way to uh just move this test
would be to like directly try and smooth
the XP right like bypass actually
finding the circuit and something which
scores
I should also say that this actually
makes sense why does it make sense
because we know that these circuits that
we have anti-concentrated
because already due to the randomness in
the
in the quadratic part of the of the
circuit we have an anti-consultation
so we actually know what started
here we go
okay
[Applause]
defense
okay so the title of this talk and uh I
guess also the question I'll be asking
is uh does
Quantum cryptography imply
uh
imply classical lower bounds
um and I guess
before I talk about the quantum version
of this question maybe I should really
start by just you know telling you uh
the analogy of this for classical
cryptography that we know the answer to
um and in particular uh I claim the
following so we know classically that
like if uh I don't know one-way
functions pseudonym generators uh you
know name your favorite uh super
polynomially secure falsifiable
cryptographic primitive if such and such
exists
foreign
then you know for example p is different
from NP so it exists uh some separation
of complexity classes that we get as a
result of cryptography and uh the
question I want to ask today is whether
something similar happens in the quantum
setting so you know can we show that
assuming some Quantum cryptographic
primitive exists that again is secure
against super polynomial adversaries uh
that there is a barrier to establishing
that unconditionally in the form of some
you know long-standing classical lower
bound that we just don't know how to
prove and that you know you would win a
million dollars for a via like the
Millennium Prize or whatever
um
so uh if you think about this question
for you know just a little bit you might
expect that you know for like similarly
trivial reasons there should just be
like a yes answer to this question
um but it's actually not so obvious
uh and intuitively the reason for this
is that uh an adversary a Quantum
adversary against some cryptographic
primitive does not operate on a
classical input it operates on a Quantum
input and for that reason it's actually
very difficult to relate the complexity
of breaking that primitive back to a
question about classical complexity
classes which only involve purely
classical inputs
and uh I think kind of the first work
that really kind of pointed this out
um
was uh oh yeah I guess a couple of Works
um by myself
in 21 and uh also joint work
in 23
where we showed that uh there exists
oracles
uh relative to which
uh first of all either
um you know
pqp equals qma
in the first result or P equals NP in
the second result
but
Quantum crypto
exists
um and so this is actually saying that
there's there's kind of not an obvious
resolution to this question in the form
of like you know if you have some
Quantum analog of one-way functions then
you must have like you know bqp is
different from qma or something
um so so saying that there exists in
Oracle this is saying that any you know
any technique for showing that you know
such a primitive implies a a separation
of these complexity classes would have
to go through uh non-relativizing
techniques and that's in direct contrast
to the classical case where these these
sorts of results hold relative to any
Oracle
um so you know at least this suggests
that you know something is different is
going on in the quantum setting and I
know at least several people who have
interpreted these kind of results as
saying that uh maybe proving Quantum
lower bounds is actually easier than
proving classical lower bounds
um perhaps we could actually hope to
have uh you know something like
pseudoanum Quantum States for example
where we can just
um you know maybe we'll it'll turn out
that we can just show unconditionally
that they exist and we don't run into a
barrier like this
um like in classical complexity Theory
and I guess in this talk I'm going to
tell you why uh
maybe you shouldn't be so hopeful about
that
um so
um yeah so where do I go next so you
know people have kind of struggled to to
relate these you know Quantum
cryptography questions back to classical
complexity questions
um but one thing we have been able to do
is to you know instead of defining uh
complexity classes where the inputs are
classical you can sort of Define uh
quantum and in that case then you can
say something sort of like this so in
particular there's a theorem uh which I
guess we heard about in Tony's talk last
week if any of you went to that
um but in case you didn't that's just by
a long list of authors
um
why 23 where
[Music]
basically they showed that uh if
if quantum cryptography
exists
in the sense that I defined earlier
meaning
um a crypto system that is not
information theoretically secure it's
only computationally secure against
polynomially bounded adversaries
if if such cryptography exists then you
can Define these Quantum classes like uh
unitary
bqp which is like a unitary version of
VPP and this is different from uh the
unitary version of P space
uh it's the set of unitary
Transformations that you can Implement
in polynomial time on a quantum computer
and similarly unitary P space is the set
of unitary Transformations that you can
Implement in polynomial space on a
quantum computer
um
and so kind of the question this this
leaves is can we relate a separation of
quantum complexity classes like this
back to a separation of classical
complexity classes or is there like a
barrier to you know showing some sort of
a connection
and
um you know I guess this is where you
know things might get a little bit hand
wavy but I kind of figure that's the
whole point of these informal talks so
um
you know informally in some of the
discussions I've had and in some of the
papers I've seen you know what what
people have kind of attributed to the
difficulty in relating a question like
unitary bqp versus unitary P space back
to say uh bqp versus P space you know a
lot of people have attributed to our
lack of understanding to this one
question which is actually a question in
query complexity
and it asks uh the following uh so yes
uh I guess I'll call it a definition so
this is the so-called unitary synthesis
problem
and it asks the following
uh does there exist a polynomial time
algorithm a polynomial time Quantum
algorithm that gets Oracle axis to some
classical function f
such that for all uh n qubit
unitary Transformations U
there exists an F
on
uh
polynomial number of bits
for which
uh
Hue implements
U
h
at least approximately
so again the statement of this is that
it asks does there exist a an efficient
Quantum algorithm such that for any n
qubit unitary you can pick some choice
of this Oracle f
such that with Oracle access to this
function f you can approximately
Implement that unitary
um and I guess another way of saying
this is basically can you always reduce
the hardness of implementing some
unitary transformation to the hardness
of implementing some classical Boolean
function
and this has been open for I think at
least 20 years in some form
and you know intuitively people have
have kind of suggested that you know
maybe this is kind of the barrier like
maybe this is why
um
it's hard to relate you know questions
like unitary pqp versus unitary piece
base
um back to classical complexity
questions
um but nevertheless as far as I know uh
no one has actually like
before this talk uh proved any sort of
rigorous connection between these
problems
and the thing I wanted to mention today
uh was kind of a cute observation that I
had that um you actually can show some
sort of connection between these
problems
and in particular
um
maybe right over here yeah
so
this is
a theorem that I observed so
suppose that
uh it turns out that the unitary
synthesis problem is easy so so there's
a positive solution to this question
there is some polynomial time algorithm
that lets you implement any unitary
um
and uh suppose that uh unitary
bqp
is different from unitary pieces
foreign
[Music]
so for example suppose that there exists
some uh Quantum crypto system uh which
would imply the separation of quantum
complexity classes
then I can show that this implies some
uh classical complexity separation that
we don't know how to prove today
in particular I can show that this
implies uh that BPP is different from NX
so VPP is bounded error probabilistic
polynomial time so this is problems that
you can solve by tossing coins on a
classical computer and polynomial time
and NX is non-deterministic exponential
time so it's it's like an exponentially
more powerful analog of NP
um and a lot of like uh people who I
talk to who you know haven't seen that
much classical complexity Theory before
are like very surprised that we don't
know how to prove that these are
different unconditionally but this is
indeed like one of the basically
research Frontier questions in classical
lower bounds
um
and yeah if we could prove this this
would be a major breakthrough
um how much time do I have so maybe I
can like
sketch some of the ideas
at least briefly
so uh
let you be something that's in unitary
EP space
so so maybe it'll actually be easier to
think about about it as like proving the
converse so like suppose unitary uh
since this problem is easy and BPP is
equal to NX I'll show you how to
implement something in unitary P space
efficiently
um then since unitary synthesis is easy
there exists in F
on
a polynomial number of bits
um
such that
you know some Quantum algorithm
implements
and kind of the whole idea is to show
how uh you know if BPP is equal to NX
you can compute this function f
efficiently you can actually find it in
polynomial time
and
uh I think this is where I'm probably
just gonna very quickly skip to the
details but
uh
I basically claim that um
there's a verifier
so you can think of this as like an NP
verifier
uh that you know given a function f
it
in exponential time
and decide
if uh this Quantum algorithm
approximately implements uh our desired
unitary U that is in unitary P space
um
and intuitively the reason for this is
that you can just
um
you know compute all of the amplitudes
uh or all of the entries of this unitary
in exponential time in the number of
qubits in the system
and you can also do the same thing on
this side so this is non-trivial like
showing that if you have a unitary that
is in uh I guess unitary piece base that
you can compute its entries and
classical exponential time but that
turns out to be true
and uh kind of the idea
is we're going to use the fact that BPP
equals NX to find this F
and
in fact there's really only one more
ingredient that we need which you know
I think I'll just state but maybe not
really go into detail about how it's
used uh it's the
empagliazzo cabinets Richardson uh easy
witness lemoth if any of you have heard
of that before
which says that if
BPP
equals NX
then
there exists a compressible
a compressible such f
so in other words if NX collects us all
the way to bqp or to BPP then it turns
out that there exists a function of this
form that actually is very succinct in
fact F can be described Itself by some
polynomial size classical circuit
um
and then using the fact that PPP equals
NX you can kind of just you know find
that uh classical circuit efficiently uh
on a Quantum device or even buy a
classical randomized algorithm uh and
then you can just plug that function f
into uh into this simulator queue and
get that uh
that U is in
unitary
uh pgp
um
so that's the proof idea
I think maybe the one thing I will leave
you with which is kind of the main
question I have that uh
relates to this
it's kind of um
supposing to the contrary
uh
suppose that actually
the unitary synthesis problem is hard
okay
um
and not only that it's hard but that
it's hard for some
explicit
unitary that's in unitary
so in other words there exists some
unitary transformation that you can
Implement in polynomial space on a
quantum computer but that such that this
unit transformation not only does not
have small size Quantum circuits it does
not have small size Quantum Oracle
circuits
and uh I guess the question is just
vaguely you know does this
imply
uh
lower bounds like classical lower bounds
because at least intuitively to me this
seems like an extremely strong lower
bound because you're saying like
you know there's some unitary that that
you can compute in like a space
efficient manner relative to you know
its size as an end by in unitary but
like it does not admit any efficient
implementation by this extremely broad
class of algorithms because it's not
just polynomial side circuits it's like
polynomial size circuits with arbitrary
classical oracles
and you know to me that seems like a
really powerful class and I sort of
intuitively expect that this should
imply you know some breakthrough in
classical complexity Theory as well but
I would be very interested to know the
answer
and I think with that I'll stop and take
any questions
[Applause]
[Music]
you know
more of you covered everything yeah yeah
so actually I think it really would sort
of cover everything because actually
here we don't even need
we just need that like unitary synthesis
is easy
for all unitaries and unitary P space
just like either so if unit is this is
an easy being in the type space you get
a lower bound and I'm sort of
conjecturing that if it's hard you
should get some other ones
so a negative resolution
so what do you mean the quest the answer
to your question is
maybe yeah yes but I don't know I think
I think it looks hard
okay
moving over on that part
of things
harder unitary yeah
yeah
that's sort of exactly the question like
can you do that yeah
so so uh
you're saying this is like the converse
to like
so you said if USP is easy for the whole
human phrase in the HTTP is not equal to
Max
I suppose the other thing is true yeah
it has to be something that doesn't look
like EPV is not equal to next otherwise
you're gonna separate because
uh assuming Quantum cryptography exists
but like if you just show that Quantum
photography implies VPP equals
PTV is different from NXT I don't know
if that would be that surprising
can we get some implication of that form
so I was just confused because uh yeah
there's
oh I see like I suppose USP is hard and
Quantum cryptography exists yeah then
lower balance
okay
thank you
[Applause]
so hello everyone thank you for
indulging until the end and we are going
to present today some constant depth
Quantum circuit for ucg Gates uniformly
controlled gate uh oracles for Boolean
function and application to Quantum
memory circuits
so the key I guess of our construction
is that we propose circuits that are in
constant depth and for this we use some
multi-qubit unbounded entangling gates
um but first since we apply our
construction to Quantum memory we have a
question for you and the question is
what is a quantum computer with access
to memory so we try to come up with a
formal definition we are not aware of
other formal definition of quantum
computer we have access to Quantum
memory so if you know some please
and yeah our model is the following so
we have a Quantum Processing Unit so a
quantum computer with a workspace whose
size is polylog in the size of a memory
and then you have an address register a
size is logarithmic in the size of a
memory so you need only login bits to
address and memory cells a Target
register of size L we can pick L equal
to uh to one for Simplicity in these
slides and then you have a Quantum
memory device that shares the address
register and the target register and on
top of that it has some mancillas and
the memory qubits that you want to
address
okay and the address register and the
target register are shared between the
quantum processing units and the quantum
memory device
so calling a Quantum
Quantum memory device is implementing
this mapping here so
you have a function that takes these
inputs the index register and gives you
a two qubit unitary from a constant
sites set and it applies the unitary to
the ith memory cell in the memory and
the target register
so practically this means that if you
have a normal Quantum memory like the
Bucket Brigade for example what you're
applying here is a C note so controlled
on the ith memory register we apply a
NOS on your target register
all right
any comment on this computational model
good
basically yeah it's like a
generalization of theorem
yes for example another kind of quantum
memory device is a Cura gate
where instead of applying synods as in
the Quran case you apply control groups
so like you are swapping the target
register here BT with the its position
in the memory
and that's something that is used for
Quantum random works and element testing
things for example
sorry the question is if this model
still capture the Bucket Brigade
good question
our model capture the Q3 and
that's the beginning with humans this is
the most related
Yeah by going around yeah
[Music]
yeah probably
there is a
blog where we had probably not sure
um okay so for our constructions we use
uh free Magic Gates so the first is the
thinning gate
and uh the Fanning gate is basically
applying uh this function f of x to our
Target register B
and famous examples of uh Athen gates
are the end function majority exact
Gates Dior Gates and so on
and the thin out Gates is basically
visualization of C naught where instead
of having one knot you have other knots
Okay so
um
and then you have a global tunable Gates
which is a kind of basically the product
of controls that Gates where you have
one parameter for the phase of Z gate
okay and
um
yeah all these gates in the bounded
setting are physically implementable
so obviously we don't claim that these
gates are implementable in the unbounded
case in practice but the bounded cases
definitely feasible
and also we need these results from
previous literature well it's very
simple to see that the fan out gate is
equivalent to parity
you just need to sandwich the fan out
gate with adamars and you you have a
parity gaze
and then the end and the or gate
equivalently can be exactly implemented
in constant depth using a linear number
of and up Gates and and login and Silas
this series of work started with royal
and schwalek and then
to have a more physical implementation
of the engine or gate you can use four
GT Gates and the linear number of
concealers
okay
so
while we let you think about this
meaning of this circuit which which
microphone
okay so let's allow we're going to start
showing our results so the
among many results that we have we
propose a Quantum second it comes on
that for kiram as Alexander toad so
that's the depict of the of the circuit
so like try to explain briefly what we
need to we need first like do some
copies of your address register and when
you do the copying we're gonna do some
this part here is we're gonna do
calculate the one hot encoding of the
address which is me is an exponentially
larger uh mid string whose nth entry is
one and the other end is at zero so once
you do this with and you need to compare
this with using and gate and once you
have the Holy code in this master you
just compute like a parity gate
so I think of course implementing the
Zen Gates will be true but the circle
itself is is quite simple
and then we go
so we've we proposed many constructions
uh for kiram and kirag so we showed the
best ones were retained so for example
we can retain like basically linear
number of concealers and fennels for
qram and just a few number of gates for
a number of GT Gates if you wanna if you
allow more and still you can decrease
the number of GT gauge to from 62 and
similar to Kira
and then the next the last slide we
generalize is to constructing any
Fanning gate and I'm not going to go
through the results but they we proposed
many many constructions that rely on
different properties of the function you
implement
so one of these functions one of these
properties that we came up with is this
this idea of like Jr hunter that we we
propose and we haven't seen this
anywhere else so what we say about a
Boolean function is or any other
function a function that depends so
enable a function that depends uh is
if you can find a set J when if you fix
the coordinates outside it's at j20
value and the party can be this to be
any value the resulting restrictions and
Ireland are Hunter
so a good example is the qram itself
because if you select if you fix the the
address qubit address entry then it
becomes like a a dictator function
so one question for you if they're
honest like if you've seen these
properties similar profits being studied
anywhere else we haven't uh being
anything and I think it's a very natural
one and I think another question we have
is that if you have seen any
non-historically constant apps that
could construction for Boolean Boolean
Arcos
I think that's it for on our part and
then yeah thank you
[Applause]
I guess another difference you can say
is that if you try to implement our
circuits in practice
and you don't have the unbounder yeah
you can go from a concept left circuit
to a circuit of log K and left
so uh circuit is number two a fan
with our construction if you have Gates
of IDK you're going to log K of n but
yeah there's another result we showed uh
I guess it's very slide that we
generalized we have even before journals
were results for this uniformly control
Gates where U of X is a single qubit
gate
and uh the the final circuit is uh one
of the constructions they started
becoming much more ugly
okay no no questions
um thank you okay
first of all I didn't understand the
results
so what are constructions like Leverage
on this property of like uh Jr Hunter so
we say like the function is if you fix
the card if there's a set on which you
could fix the the values the coordinates
and the stat to any value
the restricted function is on our hunter
so it's not
um
this is the definition yeah
is the first line I mean if if you have
if you're a function if you know your
function is then you can Implement with
that minion sealer and find out LG gate
so for example is basically like
explanation number of t plus r for
example if you can already applied this
qram because qram is a sub case of of
fenine with the selection function and
the selection function is a as a fine
example when the the size of the the
complement the t is log n and R is one
[Music]
[Applause]
um
excuse me